>>> THE TRUMP CIRCUS IS BACK ON
TOUR TONIGHT IN OHIO.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS CERTAIN
WILL ROLL OUT A CLOWN CAR FULL
OF LIES TO THE OUTRAGE OF
SUPPORTERS.
>> WE HAVE A LOT OF THINGS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
THAT WAS AN ELECTION THAT I
DON'T THINK -- ALL YOU HAVE DO
IS READ THE NEWSPAPERS AND SEE
WHAT'S COMING OUT NO.
NO, THE WORD IS CONCEDE.
I HAVE NOT CONCEDED.
>> YES, HE'S BEEN COMPLAINING
ABOUT A RIGGED ELECTION FOR
NEARLY EIGHT MONTHS NOW, BUT
EACH WEEK TRUMP'S BIG LIE GETS
SMALLER WHEN COMPARED TO THE
CHILLING NEW BODY CAM VIDEOS
FROM THE INSURRECTION RELEASED
BY FEDERAL AUTHORITIES
.
AND THE BIG LIE JUST GETS MORE
SAD WHEN YOU CONSIDER TRUMP HAS
BOUGHT INTO THE INSANITY THAT
HE'LL BE REINSTATED IN AUGUST.
SENDING OUT AN E-MAIL THIS WEEK
-- HAVE YOU SEEN THIS -- VOWING
HE'LL BE BACK IN 2024 OR BEFORE.
OR BEFORE?
THAT'S A NOD TO MIKE LINDELL,
THE MYPILLOW LIE WHO CLAIMS HE
CAME UP WITH THIS BOGUS TIME
LINE.
BUT HE SAID TRUMP'S
REINSTATEMENT COULD SLIDE A BIT.
SEE, LINDELL SAID HE'LL REVEAL
HIS FINDINGS AT A SYMPOSIUM IN
AUGUST AND THE SUPREME COURT
WILL HAVE NO OPTION BUT TO THROW
OUT THE 2020 ELECTION AND THEN
TRUMP WILL BE PRESIDENT AGAIN.
AND THEN ALIENS WILL LAND ON THE
WALL.
I'M JUST KIDDING ABOUT THAT.
>> IF AUGUST DOESN'T HAPPEN,
WHAT DO YOU STAY --
>> THE STATES WILL PULL IT DOWN.
THEY'RE DOING AUDITS IN EVERY
STATE.
EVERYWHERE THEY'VE DONE AN AUDIT
LIKE NEW HAMPSHIRE, EVERY PLACE
WE'VE DONE AUDITS THAT WE'VE HAD
MACHINES --
>> THERE'S A NUTS.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT HOST ON OAN
SAID ABOUT THIS THE OTHER DAY.
>> WHEN ALL THE DUST SETTLES
FROM THE AUDIT IN ARIZONA AND
THE POTENTIAL AUDITS IN GEORGIA,
MICHIGAN, PENNSYLVANIA, NEVADA,
AND WISCONSIN, WHAT HAPPENS TO
ALL THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERTHROWING THE
ELECTION?
WHAT ARE THE CONSEQUENCES FOR
TRAITORS WHO MEDDLED WITH OUR
SACRED DEMOCRATIC PROCESS AND
TRIED TO STEAL POWER BY TAKING
AWAY THE VOICES OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM?
WELL, IN THE PAST, AMERICA HAD A
VERY GOOD SOLUTION FOR DEALING
WITH SUCH TRAITORS.
EXECUTION.
>> EXECUTION.
HE SAID IT SO CALMLY.
NOW, THAT SAME HOST CLAIMS HE
WAS ONLY DISCUSSING A LEGAL
PROCESS AND WASN'T CALLING FOR
ANY EXECUTIONS, BUT JUST IN CASE
THE BIG LIE AND THE BAMBOO
BALLOTS THAT THEY THINK CAME
FROM CHINA DON'T PAN OUT FOR THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, THE SAME CAST
OF CHARACTERS ON THE FAR RIGHT
HAVE BEEN WARMING UP THEIR
LATEST CIRCUS SIDE SHOW,
SOMETHING CALLED CRITICAL RACE
THEORY.
>> AND LET ME TELL YOU RIGHT
NOW, CRITICAL RACE CONSPIRACY
THEORY IS BIGOTED, IT IS A LIE,
AND IT'S VERY BIT AS RAIST AS
THE CLAN IN WHITE SHEETS.
>> THEY'RE PROPAGANDIZING OUR
CHILDREN AND TURNING THEM AWAY
FROM FAITH.
>> IT'S A LIE.
IT MAKES AMERICANS HATE EACH
OTHER IT'S TRAGEDY IN THAT WAY.
>> DON'T BE FOOLED.
IT LOOKS AT THE RACISM THAT'S
SHAPED OUR PAST AN.
I AM DISGUSTED BY YOUR BIGOTRY
AND YOUR DEPRAVITY.
>> JUST BECAUSE I DO NOT WANT
CRITICAL RACE THEORY TAUGHT TO
MY CHILDREN IN SCHOOL DOES NOT
MEAN THAT I AM A RACIST, DAMNIT.
>> WHAT'S NEXT?
AN INSURRECTION AT YOUR LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARD MEETING?
BUT HOLD ON.
THESE SAME FOLKS ON THE FAR
RIGHT, THEY LOVE THE MILITARY,
RIGHT?
MEET GENERAL MARK MILL YRK
CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEFS OF
STAFF.
HE SAID UNDERSTANDING THE
HISTORY OF THIS NATION IS
CRITICAL TO UNDERSTAND IT.
>> I WANT TO UNDERSTAND WHITE
RAGE, AND I'M WHITE AND I WANT
TO UNDERSTAND IT.
SO WHAT IS IT THAT CAUSED
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE TO ASSAULT
THIS BUILDING AND TRY TO
OVERTURN THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA?
WHAT CAUSED THAT?
I'VE READ CARL SAY TO AND
OTHERS?
>> THAT DIDN'T SIT WELL AT FOX
NEWS WHERE TUCKER CARLSON WAS
DOING TUCKER KARLSSON.
>> HE'S NOT JUST A PIG.
HE'S STUPID.
>> IS THAT WHAT WE'RE TEACHING
OUR KIDS NOW?
THAT IT'S OKAY TO REFER TO A
GENERAL AS A PIG?
HIS COLLEAGUE LAURA INGRAHAM WAS
SOUNDING LIKE SHE WANTS TO
DEFUND THE MILITARY.
>> WE'RE PAYING FOR THAT?
WHY IS CONGRESS NOT SAYING WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU A PENNY
UNTIL ALL OF THIS IS ERADICATED
FROM THE BUDGET.
THIS IS MY OFFER.
WE'RE OFFERING TO YOU, NOTHING.
I'M TOTALLY OUTRAGED BY HIM AND
HIS RIDICULOUS RESPONSE TODAY.
>> PRIVATE INGRAHAM, PRIVATE
CARLSON, WHAT IS YOUR MAJOR
MALFUNCTION.
THE GENERAL HAS SEEMED TO HAVE
TOUCHED A NERVE.
WHAT IS SO THREATENING ABOUT
TRUMPISM.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE BIG
LIES.
IT'S ABOUT PITTING ONE SET OF
AMERICANS AGAINST ANOTHER OVER
THE ELECTION, OVER A CRITICAL
RACE THEORY, OR WHATEVER THE
NEXT UNSERIOUS OUTRAGE THEORY
COMES OUT OF FOX NEWS OR
MAR-A-LAGO.
IF WE STOP FIGHTING EACH OTHER
AND START EMBRACING THE TRUTH,
THESE GUYS OVER HERE, THEY'RE
GOING TO RUN OUT OF THINGS TO
TALK ABOUT.
AND MAYBE EVEN RUN OUT OF MONE